I
welcome to the green room of the first
glance film festival area at Raleigh
studios in Hollywood my name is David
Brandon of la talk radio's film courage
and guess what I'm sitting on a couch
with mr. Nick baisley of film snob recom
please no batteries I think for for
talking and then taking the time to come
out and see me it's an honor to finally
meet you guys I'm really really excited
thank you thank you so much for being a
part of everything we're doing and we
love being a part of what you're doing
this is special time special times here
and how this is special for for care and
I we're very thrilled to have the
opportunity I want to go right to it for
everyone watching I know you're coming
off of DIY days in New York I'm curious
is there something that has stood out
something that may be crystallized I'm
during your time there's something you
can share for everyone watching yeah one
of the one of the there are very few
very really great speeches that happened
over at DIY days Jeff Gomez's when he
was talking about transmedia was number
one the one that I think is most it's
going to be more pertinent to the
independent film community though is the
idea of innovation and how there you
know in the independent film community
there's a lot of talking and not a whole
lot of walk in and I I understand that a
lot of that has to do with you know just
people are working on their own projects
budgets and time and everyone's got real
lives sometimes you know jobs and stuff
they've got to go to and it's very
difficult but brian newman actually gave
a speech on innovation saying that at
its core he basically said that if we
don't legislate innovation then the
suits will the suits in studios will and
i felt that was really powerful and i
really thought about that I've written
an article on film snobbery com not too
long ago that it was entitled all film
critics are wrong and part of that was
saying that part of the the problem with
film critics even was that we because of
how
no we talked about film in the standards
we have for film that a lot of times it
curbs in innovation because we want
stories and films to to be stuck in this
box that you know it's basically molded
from all the films before it i basically
brian newman was trying to talk to the
independent film community about taking
innovation into our own hands your own
hands and and making you work for you
get getting some truly innovative ideas
out there before just studios have an
opportunity to make it prohibitive for
you and i thought that was really
powerful and and I mean do you have any
of those ideas that anything that
filmmakers you know where are we going I
mean what's next you know what would you
say is next you know do are we seeing
some some cutting-edge things happening
things we should be paying attention to
yeah there's there's a lot of things out
there that people are trying to do I
mean obviously with advances in the
internet people are able to communicate
a lot easier it allows for crewing up
and casting a lot easier mean people now
are doing their casting rather than
casting couches like this doing the call
with the Catholic oh well we'll see what
happens after the cameras turned off but
no I mean but rather than getting
getting actors and actresses in front of
you initially you can you can watch the
reels online then you have you know you
have other people out there like myself
where we're trying to connect
independent filmmakers with larger
audiences through whether it's to our
web show film snobbery live you guys are
doing the same thing with film courage
and your film courage Interactive's
getting getting of independent
filmmakers out kind of on the streets
talking about their films screening
their films in public it's a really good
opportunity for for people to connect
with their audience and expand those
circles that's one of the biggest
problems right now that i think the
independent film community has that
we're all very close-knit we all kind of
know each other we're all in the
community we all kind of baked our
cookies in the same kitchen a big
problem with that is for us to reach
wider audiences we have to bust out of
that mold and dare I say it goes
slightly more mainstream with some of
the the ways that we reach our audiences
you know we have all have very
interesting stories to tell I think we
all have very unique ways of telling
them but we meet that we need to get the
wider audience and get audiences
involved in order to to get to take
advantage of the people who do want to
see independent film but aren't
necessarily in a position to know about
something you know a smaller release
like a one-hour fantasy girl or what's
up lovely hi Gary so you know the people
need to go out to think outside the box
a little bit on that and innovate new
ways I mean Aaron crumley is working
with open India's ways as a way to to
help people connect with movie theaters
to get their stuff screening using all
kind of a demanded type of situation you
know I think that and then there's other
filmmakers like Mary mazi oh just may
have a straight-up deal with AMC to have
her documentary 10 9 8 shown at AMC
theaters and limited runs and even some
of them were free screenings for
students you know catering to the stuff
like that there's there's deals to be
made out there I think that one of the
biggest problems is that independent
film unlike the studios lacks a cohesive
brand to something that people can go to
to to just basically on a
business-to-business level deal with you
know camera companies deal with
equipment companies and stuff like that
and I think that it makes it very
difficult for a one-on-one to deal with
that kind of stuff to help defer costs
and stuff and get movies made get them
promoted get them you know all that kind
of stuff it's very difficult it's such a
wide wide industry I mean 12,000 movie
independent movies I think the number
was thrown out at one point 12,000
independent movies were made last year
and that's just in the United States
alone so we need to reach worldwide
audiences that's the key we have the
world wide web now we need to reach
worldwide audiences so
however that happens make it happen are
still mine